[Music]
so there's like the super awkward thing
you have to get good at or at least
comfortable with and it's the thumbs
inwards behind the back position because
there's all these moves we do like this
where if you're turning your thumbs
inwards super graceful swish whether
it's split time or same time but if
you're trying to go like this thumbs out
it's a lot more awkward yeah you can do
it that way but it's often a lot more
awkward so this just means well I guess
go give me five
I ran behind it would be awkward to go
give me five around but you have to go
this way so you can take a poi and make
sure you get Nick you're right boy make
sure you're in this position and just
get used to making circles one way and
the other way and look at my fingers and
wrists are really kind of scooping your
fingers in your wrists to make circles
one way and the other way and make sure
it's in that tucked under thumb in
position one way the other way and then
it's gonna be really useful you can
short you put on your fingers and it can
be a little awkward at first don't worry
but you want to try to get this feeling
with both the hands thumbs in not
together thumbs pointing in or you can
circle one way and the other way and it
can be totally floppy at first I just a
little bit of success will go a long way
chirp-chirp
you stand against the wall to get a
feeling for this
if you work on that when you go to do
let's say the hip reels you want to pass
through that position you want to get
over the urge to go like that or like
this or like that or both hands I mean
that knots give me ten so a little
awkward even from say we just face this
way we have to thumb up
you can practice just going upside down
and what'll happen right away is for a
lot of you is you'll lose your plants
and that's totally wrong what we all go
through this so you can just go one
circle and back one two and back and
that can take come back that you know a
few days in a row and it's just your
brain really has to rewire it for most
people I did for me but before long a
bit ago and you'll be able to have that
mapped so to speak so that you can just
spin a circle like that and then all of
a sudden your brain understands what's
going on with the PO in your hands in
this funny position and then everything
gets easier so it takes a little bit of
work not that much and it's totally
worth it let me know that makes sense
[Music]